it's being reported that Republicans you  know they don't really have access to  Trump they can't really get to him so  they're now appearing on Fox News  because it's the only way to directly  speak to President Trump  Republicans are going on Fox News just  to talk to the president mom yes in fact  just this morning on Fox and Friends  Melania Trump called in to say I want a  divorce  Wow you can't get in she can't get in so  you know if you want to reach me it  would not be Fox News that would not be  the show to appear on if you want to  talk to me directly bachelor in paradise  is where you can find me yes do you  watch bachelor in paradise  no I don't i watch bachelor in hell it's  a much it's on pay-per-view yeah